warning if the following video is
relatable to you you may be suffering
from workaholism you work way too much
you're the first to arrive at the office
and the last to leave work is your happy
place you come to work even when you're
deathly ill indifferent to spreading
your nasty germs to your co-workers your
body hates you you have no concept of
work-life balance your idea of leisure
is watching the occasional episode of
Parks and Recreation before turning in
you always work when you're not supposed
to you have neglected all the
relationships in your life cancelling
plans so you can get a head start on
next week's work your social life has
been diminished to occasionally like in
your college buddies Facebook posts
let's not even get started on your
dating life which is nearly non-existent
never work a day in your life and I've
been on vacation now your friends try to
set you up on dates but you have
completely lost the ability to connect I
I say data instead of data just opinion
like I'm a British or something you just
can't stop working
if you fits into three or more of these
categories you are officially addicted
to work